okay so Danny what are we looking at
today we're looking at the HP Josh mark
today this is a touch compatible
computer kind of like it all in one cut
the imac but you can use your fingers to
touch the screen and gesture around and
control different aspects on the desktop
there so as far as the desktop is
considering looks like we've got video
photo calendars right and it's totally
customizable too so like you can go into
like this dock right here and bring
programs up oh my god or just open them
or just open them to you can just do
that as you can see parts of this this
touch compatibility or not fully baked
yet yeah that's one thing I notice
especially with the scroll you kind of
get this almost liquidy smooth response
from an iphone where's it's a little bit
more jittery here it's kind of jagged
area yeah which I did not like I did not
find that to be a very pleasant user
experience yeah and that's the funny
thing is that's actually HP's interface
to this is the touchsmart interface you
can actually back out to Vista and you
still have control of the cursor via the
touchscreen but it's it's you know just
like using a regular mouse you're not
really getting anything special and you
also have to deal with vista to which is
never pleasant experience that's true
and although the touchsmart does have
four gigs of ram this is running vista
premium at 64 bits so half of that is
pretty much devoted to the operating
system when you fire it and one thing
that I liked about it is that it's got
this nice 22 inch screen even though
it's touch base you don't really see a
lot of the fingerprints either it's got
a 500 gigabyte hard drive and it's also
got a TV tuner in it as well so what did
you think of the touchsmart is like a
home entertainment hub like a living
room type computer because that's
obviously that's why HP is going for I
don't know actually I don't think I put
it in looking room I think I probably
put it in the kitchen just but yeah just
because well for high-definition content
look at the inputs and outputs it has
s-video out a TV in so so you have
high-definition content on it so you
have a high-definition TV ok ok you're
going to want to pop that high
definition content out from the computer
onto your high-definition set right well
how you gonna do with this ok so no hdmi
component okay good point good point
thank you but with the media center
remote with the wireless I mean it's
obvious with the speaker bar to that
it's made for like a 10-foot almost like
a television like experience yeah i
don't think i would put this in living
room I think this belongs in its
probably belongs in like an office I
think that's like the perfect space for
it to know that makes it I think that I
think there's a lot of other computers
on the market right now that can stream
that high-definition content actually
belong in the living room and I just
don't I think this this computer falls
short in a lot of those areas so what I
give this is reading on a scale of say a
one to ten one good time where are the
balls blue balls would you get I
probably get six blue balls out of 10 16
see it's a solid product but just has
some issues I think the future
generations of this product are going to
be better especially when more
competition comes out into the
marketplace so say Apple releases a
version of this computer I think it'll
actually help yeah i agree i mean it
seems like HP has got the right idea
other companies like the dell one there
obviously you know the all-in-one market
is blowing up slowly but no one's really
tackling the touchscreen so it's great
that HP wants to lead the charge as far
as that's concerned but you probably
want to wait a while before you invested
I say third or fourth generation will be
yeah pretty good